tell us this story from the circus when
you were seven years old ten years old
yeah it's actually yeah ten years old
ten years old it was a bizarre
experience but um yeah and a
life-changing one but this isn't burn on
Trent those that don't know burn on
Trent it's like right in the middle of
the UK you know it's like there's no you
know it's his land with land based you
know there's no sea for miles around and
so it was a boiling hot day ten years
old someone came knocking on the door it
was my brothers it was my brother's best
mate and he came around asking if we
could asking if we wanted to go swimming
mum was like yep couldn't wait to get
out out of her hair and and then we set
off and as we got down to the swimming
baths we actually saw that the big top
was setting up in town and we're like
wow the Chipperfield circus is in town
amazing so excited young boys we like I
walked ended to to a run and before we
knew it down at the big tops
and saw the first guy down there said
look can we have a look around and he
said yeah yeh said we're just setting up
there's animals out but they won't
change you'll be okay and and that's
that's it we went into the big talk and
I can remember I got separated from my
brother and his may and and their I
don't know what drew me towards it but
on the other side there was an opening
and I was sort of drawn to that opening
and as I got to it the Sun hit me in the
eyes I couldn't see for a moment and
then as my vision cleared there it was
sat in front of me about 10 15 metres
away was something that just amazed me
and I was absolutely compelled to go
towards and that was a baby chimp and
before I knew it you know I walked over
cautiously and there it was you know for
me I bought up with with Tarzan Johnny
Wiseman black-and-white films you know
and for me that was a little piece of
Hollywood sat right there it was amazing
and next thing I'm stood over it ten
years old and it looked up at me with
these beautiful eyes and it was a moment
we connected and it sounds weird I know
but we connected and it was it was just
surreal baby chimp Goes Down Peaks
some food off the floor starts passing
it to me and I'm like wow this is a this
is a male I felt like a miniature like
David Attenborough you know so a staff
thought gee I'm not eating that's
disgusting so I was just going through
the motions throwing it over my shoulder
and it probably only went on for 20-30
seconds but it seemed like a lifetime
you know I was brought up with cats and
dogs this was a chimp you know middle in
middle of the UK a chimp and all of a
sudden you know it's a beautiful blue
skies and the serenity of that moment
was cut like a fighter jet racing
through the sky as I heard this roar and
I'll never forget it I can still hear
the roar to this day heard this roar and
in the shadows under a truck in the you
know behind the chimp I could see
something moving and those shadows that
movement then became clearly what was
about a 50 killings although I don't
know what size it was but I didn't get
chance to weigh it but it was bloody big
and it was it was the mother
it was the mother you know is the baby
the chimps mother which then Mac 10
started coming at me you know the old
side was chimp movement yeah exactly
you know just raging absolutely raging
and I'm like a deer in the headlights
thinking oh my god
and at the points I thought you know
this is the moment you should move
you know this chimp just fired straight
up into the air I was watching this
things it was just rising higher and
higher in the air the blue sky turned to
black as this thing landed on me and
then started going to town on me pinned
me down to the floor I was pinned to the
floor and it was like a drummer in a
rock band
you know it's fist coming down on to me
and she was tearing chunks out of me and
it was just it was it was mental
absolutely mental arm lay there and I
just remember thinking I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die unless I do something I'm
gonna die and it was in that moment that
I knew that I had to take a step into
that I had to take a step into further
discomfort for any chance of living that
day okay so I managed to
sort of moved my body just a few inches
and I dislodged the chimp I managed to
get my knee up to my chest I kicked the
chimp in the in the chest and it just
give me a couple of feet just to get
away and then this chimp gets back to
its free and he's coming at me you know
final attack it's got it's got blood
dripping from its teeth it was my blood
and and then it came at me and then a
chain Court around the neck just before
it got to me and I was stood there you
know ten year old absolutely in a state
of shock my arm was like a you know a
bone that had been chewed by dog or
laughter it was just a mess you know
he's like um it was it been ripped apart
there was blood all over me and it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't a good thing
a good sight the whole place erupted and
and then they got me off to hospital as
quickly as possible where he stitched me
up and and that was that really that was
that was the the that was the attack
that happened at 10 years old you know
and ya know it sounds like something out
of a movie may well when I look back you
know sometimes it's hard for me to
actually understand it wasn't until
recently and I've talked about this in
the book that I opened up that chapter
in my life again but always looking back
up until that moment it was like a movie
in my head you know it was yeah have you
got any of them have you got any scars
from when it happened that you can still
see that visible yeah I mean I've got my
arm here which you can't really see I
mean that's the Scott that's the big
scar there I mean it's ten its healed up
a lot but that there has been this big
chunk that's gone out of that that there
so I've lost no function in my arm but
um but yes I mean that this the scars
really were the ones you can't see you
know and but you know I always look back
on that and I understand now looking
back there when something happens like
that in your life you can just we
naturally lock away the intimate
emotional detail we just soothe oh
that's way wide but you you need to
address that and and
and to think you can have something like
that happened to you in that not affect
your life especially 10 years old
is absolutely it's naive woman scars are
proof that you're stronger than whatever
tried to kill you and that's that's
truly both true for both internal and
external
[Music]
you